en ce début d'année 2021 permettez moi
de vous adresser mes meilleurs voeux
pour l'ensemble du monde sportif de
notre département de la vienne monde
sportif que vous soyez sportif amateur
professionnel mais aussi pour l'ensemble
des dirigeants et l'ensemble des
bénévoles qui malgré un contexte
sanitaire difficile ne nous permettent
pas de pouvoir suivre nos championnats
quelques nous aimerions le faire
soyez assuré que le département est
toujours à vos côtés
côté du monde sportif et que si nous
pouvons être présents au match
eh bien nous sommes tout de même à vos
côtés en tant que partenaire et surtout
en ce qui concerne les pb 86 avec cette
passe difficile qu'ils subissent en ce
moment tant par l'aco ville que par la
problématique du changement d entraîneur
et des changements de joueurs
elia sachez que nous espérons de tout
coeur et bien que ce sera la victoire
pour le match à domicile
michel jean mai prochain et que malgré
un championnat huit lots eh bien nous
serons à vos côtés
par le biais du live
le département de la vienne s'est
toujours engagée auprès du monde sportif
que cela soit le club amateur des clubs
professionnels de l'ensemble des
associations
le sport est avant tout un moyen de
sociabilisation extraordinaire et le
sport a toujours véhiculé des valeurs
sportives et des valeurs morales
importante que nous avons à coeur bien
entendu d'accompagner